доброго вечора я газів міста та
виховати та 20 дим призначаєш форма та
масивного піт ринку міністерство свято
та науки україни ягоди в ефірі
продовжимо купувати з психологом це
відомому українцями ще до того, як з
бригада адекватні matin та стан [ __ ] та
ну скажемо і так ефективним до
продуктивним часом величини просто
даєте кожному з нас цьому сьогодні ми
запаси ви біжіть до волю рушити
паховий психолог клінічний психолог
практикуючий психолог ольга б резовська
думаєш що пак детально ми знаємо
сьогодні програму про ти як знайти себе
і повернути я йду собі і яксо бнф стирчать
цій у вас привіт
танки з'єднати на взаєм ольга але
владно та харчування до ми задаємо всім
нашим гостям c
тисячу за раз g8 ти ж довжини прийшов
рецепту досить багато хто з нас
думаєш я буду настільки довго і у всіх
справа скажемо ось так туризмом і зайняти
змінилася і ситуація змінилася і тоді
ось як у вас тісні колишні ви прийшли і
проходьте
для мене таке ось слово, яке в мене
вилітає відразу ж це я
стійко
як і у всіх 5 ранку до мене прийшло це
звістка але
якось я домовилася про свою психіку і
того самого дня за 24 я якось
увімкнулась
якоюсь мірою звичний робітник
процес хоча до цього можливий у мене
було більше роботи з дітьми ніж зі
дорослими зараз ось коли
прийшла війна до нас у мене більше
практика перейшла у дорослій частині
критичного
[музика]
я знаю точно що війна це те що
таке зло яке точно не має жодних
смішків але війна точно не скасовує сенс
і які обов'язково проступлять які
обов'язково
позначити своє власне життя
так це факт, що концепція цінності вона
правда дуже похитнулася, але сенс і вони
начебто ще більше зростають і
якщо звернути увагу саме на зміст та
сенс людини, що прийшла в життя
ну тобто
глобальному розумінні
це вижити і
потім коли ти вже вижив залишитися
щасливим зробити своє життя якимсь
таким чином обставити її щоб ти був
щасливим тому що
поняття яке багатьом відоме яка
говорю Ісус вас 2 ближнього як самого
себе в цьому є дуже велике значення що
ми не можемо начебто
полюбити когось або допомогти комусь якщо
цього немає у нас є спочатку я як їх
літаку говорять і спочатку надягаємо на
себе та
рятівну бутику а потім
як би дуже багато полягає потім
ось владна рахунок готова до надії ти на
події ритуальну маску часто бувають
також ми потрапляємо в темні нестабільний
м синус там і
дуже можемо ефективно ліжка на обличчі
бою своїми серпанком ми-то своїм ідеям я
говорю про просто на піку там на ви ж не
до паніки та тривожності обом крок
установки треба я нам потрібно влади буде
особлива ось тему контексті як знайти
мастило d і взяті я києва хрестового тут
готові щоб повернутися та ну до суду
слова адекватного стану поводжуся
класно
так ось останнім часом це дуже частий
взагалі питання та запит про те, що я не
розумію де я я не відчуваю себе я
почуваюся
начебто без якоїсь приналежності
наші
співвітчизники вони дуже багато
виїхали за кордон і хтось у
когось є почуття провини, тобто люди
дуже багато хто приходить
терапію саме з цим запитам про
почуття провини
те, що я не можу ніяк вплинути
що
там багато чого намішано у тому числі
синдрому вижив що я все щось
роблять а я нічого не роблю або навіть ті
хто залишилися припустимо у нас у країні вони
багато хто може говорити я роблю менше ніж
чим робить хтось така такий внутрішній
конфлікт начебто постійна
недооцінка порівняння себе стінка а
є це ось поняття самооцінка взагалі
слово самооцінка в ньому є корінь
оцінювання та
самооцінка вона дуже відрізняється від
самоцінності
самоцінність це коли ти не
не порівнюєш себе з іншими тобто
коли особистий фокус на себе
тому що зараз це ось така ось важка
обстановка тільки ніби на себе від
цього фокусу йому не вистачає і важливо
пам'ятати що я ось як я
така велика зв'язка між
емоціями
що ми переживаємо на емоційному плані
так чи інакше відображається на нас
фізично навіть є ось таке поняття в
життя на які багато хто не звертає
увага просто в нашій звичайній
повсякденному житті
ось хто там ходить на роботу чекає ходить
на роботу
щось його там на роботі не влаштовує
він не стільки такий похмурий чи може
бути якось у плечах стиснуті
коли несе рюкзак до цього це дуже
відчувається начебто ось він його
несе прям плечима потім що тобто
затискач і відбувається на рівні тіла на
рівні фізики діалоги та
припустимо цю людину там підвищили
на посаді
підвищили на посаді або щоб там
гарні сталося
коли трохи вгору разів у тепличці
розправилися потім за ось цим ось
підвищенням, наприклад, відбувається щось
ще гарна і в нього там раз і тягнувся
та й
потім багато людей можуть який прикладу
ніякого відношення не мають до спорту
потім такі рази я хочу піти на спорт
і починає займатися якимось спортом
при тому кожна людина обирає собі
різний спорт хтось там йде сила вуку
якусь хтось там іде не знаю на
пілон підлогу денс він займатися цією
красивою важко
хтось йогою важливо що через мозок
так кажуть усі
фізіологи ті хто вивчають мозок що ми його
учимо вивчаємо вивчаємо і про нього
нічого не знаємо, а він знає про нас він
знає про нас прям дуже дуже багато
наперед і
ось цей мозок відправляє сигнал і ми
Йдемо в якийсь спорт і в цьому спорті
тобто чомусь саме цей спорт ми
вибрали ми починаємо опрацьовувати своє
тіло тобто і я ось сьогодні хочу дати
деякі і
практично штуки, які важливо потрібно і
можна робити для того щоб повернути
собі себе у мене до цього повернулася я
[музика]
трохи приклади як це працює зв'язки
багато хто знає такий ось що якщо тобі там
погано наприклад то потрібно протягом
сорока семи секунд посміхнутися і тоді
імпульс цей міст що
нормально і
механізм включається включається
запускається і дійсно стає
все нормально це класний такий спосіб
його можна використовувати коли наприклад так
дуже поганий стан там поганий від
тобі треба ось зараз тримати обличчя і
тоді його можна застосувати мозок увімкнеться
і в тебе прямий вийде але це загрожує
якщо таким чином постійно себе як
ніби запікувати то потім так чи
інакше буде обман відбувається деяка
blanc самообман себе обман потім це так
чи інакше вилізе десь
психосоматичний фізично
тобто десь там з'явиться грудка в горлі
тому що
щось у тебе сталося від і не
висловився не вибирався десь з'явиться
нежить тому що тобі було боляче
неприємно а ти не ви плакався і тому
не ось звідси ось такий буде
виходити тобто важливо пам'ятати що весь
емоційний
національний план був дуже пов'язаним
зік
ось і
так я вже сказала що я повернуся до таких
ось способом коли повернути собі себе
перед цим хочу ще сказати що
що ми маємо вплив начебто
тільки на три метри три споловиною метри
який від нас тут люди які йдуть у
ланка щоб всі щось роблять там до
Наприклад або я поїхав ну тобто ось таке
по перше
знову ж таки повертати повертаючись до мозку
мозок знав що нам треба виїхати
або мозок знав що треба залишитися ми не
знаємо а мозок працює на наше виживання
тобто начебто це найкращий
вихід для мене для того, щоб я врятував
себе цим врятував якесь оточення
свої зримо та так та свої три метри то
є ми маємо можливість керувати ось
цими трьома з половиною метри me якщо
щось знаходиться за межею наших 300
міліметрів то у нас є можливість
підсунутися ближче
і тоді ми можемо наступного це що три
з половиною впливати слово це лише
реально за раз так вже актуальна
історія я бачу ціну фейсбуці
регулярно акули люди на віч важливі люди
річки займають кампуса девід в'янення був
державному секторі був бізнес пише
пости кину на кшт outta ваш читами будемо
одягати патріотів щось навпаки і
зруби бла бла бла ну ну і люблять поєднуєте
їх що коханому простолюдинам знаю там
простягну його наші просто навпроти і на
шинку наводжу його виправлено ну читаєш
така думаєш млинець сильно на його краще
заміни краще патріоти не жуючи до розрахунків
експерти не жуючи забарвленні бізнесмени нижче я
бла бла бла бла бла історії людини такий
повний комплекс попер знаю це я до
самооцінка миску і раніше все саму тингу
спаривався заркуна до інстаграма до ви там
одні хлопчик це дівчата kef від кого з і
на тлі бурдж-халіфа в дубаї на приклад
і видавав Іван їм може там один раз
нарік приходу заробити 1000 фотографія
здається що ось цьому осягнуто думаю
млинець завжди ця а я тут а за зростання
сваритися ще й на такому тлі пак
нагадуємо качину школу просто при цьому
емірати і я кровоточу вами включатися
всю історію якутського точення кривавого
ти нібито rift та владна пекло сказала
саму tennis club тієї інформації школа
домагається і порошок
знаєте
реакція реакція це ж така акція як
нібито яку неможливо скасувати те
є сказати не реагуй а
якщо я реагую чому б не реагувати
тобто якщо хтось а розумний добрий
людина не скаже не реагуй, а в мене
вона реагує то я швидше за все впаду
ще більше у провину, що хтось молодець
може не реагувати
тому
реагувати ми маємо право
реагувати на все, що відбувається і це
якраз є че начебто наша
деяка жвавість ми живемо але у цьому
важливо тут ведуть виписала перед нашою
зустріччю виписала собі кілька запитань і я
думаю що вони якраз ось сюди заходить у
це коли тобі говорять про те що ось ти
поїхав ти нічого не робиш країни чи
ось ти залишився і заважаєш виливати ну то
є ж позиції дуже прямий один в одного
степеня дзеркалять радість їй кожний у
своєму місці у своїй позиція залишається
дуже
дало б їм чи що
важливо поставити собі питання
ну тому що розум це все одно до цього
часу ми мали свої якісь ви мали
себе правда тобто ми якось жили нашу
життя якось любили наших близьких
родичів якось не любили когось
тобто у нас точно була своя якась
заможна фокус корінь дерева та
коли ми входимо в те, що хто у нас там
звинувачує як те і ще щось знову ж
фокус на три з половиною метри це дуже
важливо і ставити собі це питання хто я
та хто я явно був їсти зараз я явно
був до цього ось я хто і
деякі перерахування я той що я мати
там я друг я
ну ось усі свої якісь атрибутики ролі
у всій своїй волі архетипові
ось це питання хто я після того коли
ти позначився з тим, хто я
що я роблю
з того що я зараз там так
я пишу або я дивлюся і
продовжуючи тим що я готую їжу для
своїх дітей я там
не знаю витримую якийсь там кордон
прямо що я роблю ви очевидно щось робите
я лежу це теж щось робив, тому що
я лежу якщо я можу тільки лежати що це
про самозбереження тобто якщо організм
настільки бовтався що я можу лежати
кльово дякую тобі дякую що ти мене
зберігаєш саму справу я можу лежати це
круто що я можу дозволити собі лягти
тому що багато з останніх сил у
щось прагнуть і не дають собі
можливості своєму тілу на відпочинок щоб
набратися ресурс ні не лягають тобто
питання хто я питання що я роблю
які у мене цінності цінності у нас
точно були незважаючи на те, що вони
підкреслили, але є тут точно у нас
є якісь цінності якщо глибоко мені
подивитися там будуть і сенс
тому що для мене важливо точно залишається
частина яка для мене важлива
вранці ставити собі ці питання в
перших якщо не сталося можливості
відбитися від цього і ти пішов якимсь
чином себе там тобі складно просто
сісти дати собі час на ось це ось і
по ставити собі ці питання якщо є
можливість виписати що я хтось мої
цінності таки це я роблю ось це а
потім просто на це подивитися і там
буде дуже багато, а буде дуже багато
себе дуже кльово це прям дуже
важливо потім
що у мене є у
кожного є все, що місце в нього це
є у нього є
тіло у нього є стіл є близькі
вивести та ось виписати що в мене є
і це все та ж буде начебто
наповнювати цілісне я
практично і штуки та
[музика]
ще
що я маю і про що я можу вже
забути
[музика]
так що я можу вже забути тобто
щось за що міст чіпляється як за
минулий як би ресурс а він уже
зжив ось на сьогодні він уже не має я
чіпляю сюди і в мене туди йде дуже
багато енергії мого власного трясусь
соколом обмірковуємо з опор треба
сумніватися небеса повно кота тому що
я була там ніхто краще за перо до того ж на
буду цьому на роті
я кулаки гетсбі намотати оплату св
ліллах ліфта рак
будемо of через протоку так але є таке
поняття що без минулого начебто
немає майбутнього і минуле це куди точно
потрібно подивитись з подякою
завдяки ось тим минулим своїм помилкам
вмінням взагалі всім усім сполучним є
сьогодні я які я ну тобто ось така
ось ось такий ось і це явно завдяки
тому тому в минуле ми можемо
подивитись сказати йому дякую і
розуміти що ми можемо з ним прощатися
свою долю ми звідти взяли
я хотіла з практичних таких штук
дати
ми можемо навіть перетікати в
хочу просто таку увагу звернути на
те що
є у нас ось наше обличчя і
може якщо ми простежили колись
або можемо звернути на це увагу
що коли ми лякаємося чи злимося
наші щелепи прикладу відбувається
ніби стискаємо затискач затискач
відповідно у нас тут відбувається
м'язовий якийсь тонус by burton
знову ж таки з урахуванням того, що фізіологія
вона тісно пов'язана з психікою, тобто
якщо на рівні психіки ти вже не можеш
розслабитися хто тоді ми підемо через
тіло
мудрість і завдяки тілу ми розслабили
ось ці ось наші психічні мирончики
тобто у нашій щелепі живе дві емоції
агресивність і страх точніше страх і агресивність
страх він
попередник агресії
це найпотужніший ресурс на агресію і ми
можемо діяти просто порвемо там
всяке але первинне перед тим як
з'являється ця агресія
миготить страх такий приклад наводжу що
прикладу там йдеш ідеш дорогою йдеш
спотикаєшся об камінь
спотикаєшся балерин тобто ось перед
цим млинець млинець це вже агресія
якого фіга він тут лежить цей не могли
томас вайт відремонтувати перед цим
була первинна емоціям, а прилітаючий
звичайним страх я міг спіткнутися про так і
питань подібного бодай
впав і розбив би себе його
смерть була б неминуча
але включається швиденько країнах як
ресурс збирає нас і починається
якого фіга тут лежить
але і тоді, коли ми спіткнулися саме
найпершу секунду стався 1 раз і
потім коли це агресія особливо коли
агресія невисловлена ​​а зараз у нас
багато злості є агресор який у нас
її викликає і практично не всі мають
можливість
прямо в око даватися фута і злість і
тому це переходить сюди в цю частину та
тоді для того, щоб розслабити потрібно
читати чи здавати я це покажу
трохи схоже також є другий
момент він теж тісно пов'язаний з цією ось
частиною особи це ваші пальці наші пальці
якщо тут живе страх і злість то тут
живе спокій і тонус ну тобто як
б через пальці ми можемо зібратися
сконцентруватися і через пальці ми
можемо розслабитися що це прямо
такий фізіологічні штуки коли прямий
зовсім зовсім і немає можливості там до
приклад означає присідати
покатати колючі м'ячик якщо у тебе його
ні в тебе точно є
ти є точно ось знаєте як
таке ну цього здебільшого у чоловіків так
є це я про концентрацію та
взаємозв'язок ось це ось коли чоловіки
закручують гвоздик ну там вони роблять
[сміх]
так тобто начебто працює дрібна
моторика насправді звертається ось
сюди в артикуляцію ось це щоб
розуміти наскільки це взаємопов'язано
такий спосіб у нас у всіх є мова
скільки вам років стільки він у вас є і
він на вас працює кожен день він жує з
вами говорить з вами і простягну ми як
ніби не звертали на нього уваги і
тоді ось у ці ось моменти коли де я
зрозуміти де
в цей час приходить на допомогу мову я не
знаю владимир чи можна в цьому ефірі
показувати
здам практична частина коли можна у
мене зараз немає plo. але
люди будуть хустку чому це зручніше
робити з чимось тому, що руки ковзають
у роті для того, щоб повернути собі себе
щоб відчути що я є на
яких думка так я є я стійкий мої
ноги зараз зараз де де мої
п'яти на чому сидить моя тато чи сидить моя
попа чи стійкий мій хребет прямо
ну як би навіть
колись зовсім не дуже
добре силою силою змусити себе
подумати про те де зараз мої ніжки
які у мене шкарпетки сьогодні якщо у
кросівках тобто фокус повернути вранці
на своє тіло
повернули себе ось у це місце де де мої
ножички я мої стегна та інше
щоб прямо на фізичному відчути
себе це ми можемо взяти мову свою і
вибачте я покажу і
промацати його ось сюди прям гарненько
його промацати вздовж і гарненько я міг
промацати поперек ви здивуєтеся я просто
впевнена що він усім 9 не проробив ви потім
ще будете хвилин 20 сидіти відчуттям вау
показує, а ви ніколи б про це не
знали і ось це ось про те, що в мене
є моя мова з моїми маленькими
капіляр чеками він служить мені кілька
років не служить дякую ось це ось є
начебто повернути себе і другий
момент це тобто ми вже зробили цей
мова то
накрутили серветку якщо немає серветки
то тут є чисті руки, то тоді ми
можемо просто себе прищі промацати не
заходячи в порожнину і до речі ось про
щипати ось ці ось своєю pop
масажним лініям теж дуже важливо нам
треба розслабити цю частину, бо
тут сидить страх і злість і коли ми
це зробимо ми зрозуміємо що він фух
якось легше тобто
ось туди до рота і
ось тут ось простягаєте вздовж щоки
пайовики пайовики
свободу уроки а ще й тут
головне той що у роті щоб він не
ворушився ворушитися тільки ось ця
верхня частина чому тому що там
можете собі подряпати ви зрозумієте грам
якщо ви почнете ворушити там ви зрозумієте
що щось робиться явно не та тобто
мова та щоки і ви розумієте що я є і
ви кажете собі спасибі дякую і що я
з ось цього ось я є як я можу
діє з урахуванням того, що я первинно
враховуючи те, що я не можу нікому допомогти
якщо я не в ресурсі і якщо є ось
фізичний стан
я хочу спати треба дати собі цю
можливість виспатися
якщо є можливість виспатися
якщо нічого навколо не
бомбить тобто така можливість є
тому що ми не можемо допомогти якщо ми не
допомогли первинно собі і другий момент з
пальчиками
щодо ось цієї ось нашої частини про
концентрацію якщо ось звернути увагу
коли ми їдемо у автобусному транспорті
якомусь довго там інше місто та
стукнули у вікно дивимося у вікно
думки такі розлетілися то в нас
незважаючи на те, що у нас закритий рот
у роті у нас мова разів
розслаблений стан
ось це теж у такий спосіб теж можна
повернути саме фізіологічному рівні та
пальчики пальчики наші
знову ж таки як я кажу про те, що коли ми
крутимо і ось тут робить тобто їх
потрібно прямо поминати
якщо нам потрібно розслабитися, то нам потрібно
затиснути це для того, щоб розслабити
потрібно затиснути для того, щоб навпаки
сконцентруватися потрібно поминати
м'яз напружується
м'яз напружувати якщо по ньому простукувати
розслабляється якщо її затискаєш і ось
це ось все дуже себе
хвилі і крафтові пальці та і звичаї то в
принципі можна зібрати зараз
роботи правил.
зоря power мене так-так-так-так-так
скоєного зведу собою but i але
нормальному станини їх нормальному стане
льодом леге те, що ти роботи зможуть
примати виняток правильно
діяти із себе ми не можемо
діяти ми не можемо йти працювати
якщо у нас немає фізичного ресурсу
якщо мені погано і я хочу плакати, то я
зобов'язана собі дати цьому волю інакше
піде затик і затик піде на кого
знайти фізичному рівні знайти коли
плечі болять шия болить плече вище ти взяв
на себе багато відповідальності і не
можете помістити тіло сигналу і тоді
потрібно щось зробити з цією частиною а
взагалі я дивлюся і наших людей я розумію
що які у нас круті та стійкі люди та
насправді наскільки ви скопійовані
зараз і не дивлячись на те, які у нас
є власні більш власні
якісь негаразди
як ми тримаємось
за буду добре треба просто ніби бутану
може нашому будь-яку точку контакту про
нас кожного на протектор доп раніше там
уоллера дуже дякую вам зефір дуже дякую
за класну породу у нас таких ще не
був у і вам чесно скажу для мене це
таки рідко чашу можна за допомогу
пальців то щоки це бути
повернутий і
серце круто буду нам від цього
хреста ось таких моментів я до вас бажаю
вам вузьких вашими клієнтам обожнюю до
пункту допоможуть колишній фортеці людей там
офіційно за раз необхідно ось але йому
родом цим дякую
всім стані гарна стану варна вечора
і потрібну ночі один до завтра